...
-Annie aime les sucettes,
..les sucettes à l'anis.
Les sucettes à l'anis..
..d'Annie,
..donnent à ses baisers
un goût anisé.
Lorsque le sucre d'orge..
..parfumé à l'anis,
..coule dans la gorge d'Annie,
..elle est au paradis.
Pour quelques pennies,
Annie,
..à ses sucettes à l'anis,
..elles ont la couleur
de ses grands yeux,
..la couleur des jours heureux.
Annie aime les sucettes,
..les sucettes à l'anis.
Les sucettes à l'anis d'Annie..
..donnent à ses baisers..
..un goût anisé.
Lorsqu'elle n'a sur sa langue..
..que le petit bâton,
..elle prend ses jambes
à son corps..
..et retourne au drugstore.
Pour quelques pennies,
..Annie,
..à ses sucettes à l'anis,
..elles ont la couleur
de ses grands yeux,
..la couleur des jours heureux.
...
Lorsque le sucre d'orge..
..parfumé à l'anis,
..coule dans la gorge d'Annie,
..elle est au paradis.